organic farmer ryan casey is inspecting
this year's harvest he runs the farm
about 70 kilometers outside San
Francisco until now Casey has only sold
vegetables at the local weekend market
now he started selling his produce
online via the website good eggs it's an
exciting new avenue for farmers to to
sell their food through they are really
good at marketing and finding people and
connecting people with the food which
leaves me more time to do the growing
and to be on the farm more he delivers
his produce to the good eggs depot in
San Francisco workers then pack up
individual orders for delivery for its
service the company keeps about three
and a half percent of the sales revenues
the company was founded in 2012 and is
financed by investors from Silicon
Valley the good eggs website sells
anything that's regional and seasonal
the prices are the same as you would pay
at the weekend market deliveries cost 3
euros or you can pick up your items at a
selected location
there's a lot of people out there who
want to eat locally who want to support
the local community you want to support
the producers are doing things right but
it's just not very convenient others to
Sarah pasquinelli buys her produce
through good eggs she gets your orders
delivered to her door the mother-of-two
says the service saves her treasured
time tedious visits to the supermarket
are now a thing of the past
I don't even remember love I went to the
store for anything other than bananas
and string cheese those are maybe the
two gaps the good eggs website provides
background information on all its
providers customers can even visit the
farms and producers to test the food's
quality for themselves around 400 local
suppliers take part the concept is
catching on around the world German
dairy company Hema puts a barcode in
each of its milk containers using the
code customers can see a live video feed
of the cow that produced their milk they
can also use the website to order their
next milk delivery in London the
delivery startup hub of is making
shopping easy and fun huh bubs website
lets you order from dozens of local
shops from the comfort of your home the
company then collects the produce and
delivers it to your door
in the US the good eggs service model is
so successful they've already opened up
new branches in New York and Los Angeles
the company now wants to expand
worldwide shift says eat fresh